last time we talked we talked about the
kind of your particular user experience
when it comes to booking travel right in
the process that you go through
um can we talk about that a little bit
in terms of where it starts and then
what the kind of uh workflow looks like
for you yeah well it depends what kind
of travel it is so I just went on
I just went on vacation yeah that's fine
yeah I just went on vacation and that
that impulse of the cation was different
than the other kinds of travel I do and
the process was different because now
you're negotiating with the fan the
whole family right like the kid and it's
like where should we go you know oh
shoot let's go to a beach somewhere well
you can't fly because the kids are too
young and you know and you just have
this weird conversation that goes for a
couple weeks right and then you start
sort of saying okay I'm going to La but
we don't really don't know where we want
to go and you just hold on and I and so
there's a discovery process of a couple
of weeks to figure out because that's
sort of fun it's vacation should be fun
it's like where should we go I don't
know you know let's figure out where we
should go and it's fun to talk about
that I mean we're even now talking about
next year's vacation it's like you know
so we'll talk about for all a whole year
right and before we finally decide on a
place and stuff like that it's for fun
but the the kind of travel I usually do
is I uh I know I have to go to the Web
Conference in Paris in December and
that's decided and it's a hard date I
can't move it I can't move the location
so the vacation is like
we could move everything all the way up
to the last minute you know it's like
nah we don't want to go to La let's
cancel everything let's go to
Jacksonville you know we could do that
if it's vacation because there's nobody
on the other side that's waiting for us
and it's vacation is fun we're
um
uh business travel is your boss wants to
meet you with you in headquarters you
better go or a customer you got to go
and pitch a customer or you go to go
do a presentation and those places are
decided for you and the times are
deciding free pre-fast and they're hard
they're not movable you can't move the
wet the web is in December and it's in
Paris and it's not going to move so
travel for business is is different
animal from that standpoint but yeah
when I my first time I communicate that
with the world is to go to plancast and
say I'm going to the web you know and
then I started saying okay it's December
whatever I forget what the date is but
12th through the 15th let's say and then
you go and you start putting that on
your counter making sure you don't have
any conflicts
um then you start negotiating with your
boss hey boss I want to go to the web I
got invited to speak or something like
that can you pay for the travel and
they're paying for the hotel or you know
so you have to negotiate costs
or you know who's paying for what or or
you know or am I just kind of expenses
and then you start making travel plans
like okay now I have to go to kayak and
start or act if you work for a big
company you go into their Travel
Planners and say find me a flight on
these days it's also this question of
disposable income right when you're
sitting and you're making your entry
into plan cash you've got the greatest
amount of cash related to that trip by
the time you hit the fourth four square
chat that's not discretionary that's
like when I when you travel you're gonna
spend money right because one you have
to buy a flight and you know if you're
gonna go to Paris you gotta fly there
right no alternative unless you want to
swim
they have an app for that yeah I don't
think so you know
um and you're gonna buy a hotel
and and you're probably gonna have a few
dinners there you're probably gonna have
you know there is some discretionary
income like oh I I want to spend a
couple extra days there and go to the
moon and go to the Eiffel Tower and you
know and have some fun and go to some
cafes you know so and that's where the
discretion and discretionary piece is
but but the reason you're there is to go
to the web and that's why your boss is
paying for it and you know and you had
to negotiate with your boss about that
but but I think the point was
you'll never have more money to spend
than the day you decide right because
then you buy your plane ticket and that
money's gone that money is locked in you
know if you went to United Airlines
Virgin America can't come in and go hey
can you switch to us and I'm sorry I
actually spent the ra but they could
have gotten you 24 hours before right
you know before you bought the ticket
and they could have said hey we have a
special deal with 800 and you're paying
1500 on United you know and we have a
better service you know and so there
could be it could have been a
negotiation thing I mean that's where I
think series is going to be really
interesting it's like I need a flight
from San Francisco to Paris on December
15th returning on December 19th you know
go find me the best flight it'll
negotiate with these services and find
the best fair and then I might come back
and say this one's a little bit more but
it's Virgin America you know it's virgin
do you want to fly virgin or you want to
fly United and you're so and your social
graph is saying that the experience on
Virgin makes the difference worth it
it's not even that I'd like I'd love to
see
you know because there's gonna be 50
people from
California flying to right which plot
planes are they all on I mean right sure
which plays with Wi-Fi and so that's
where you get weird privacy stuff right
because it's like
you know if let's say Ashton Kutcher is
keynoting it in Paris he doesn't quite
want every fan of his in the world to
know he's gonna fly you know Virgin
America on this on this date right today
right but but maybe he you know I mean
when we had lunch he checked in on
Foursquare and nobody came and attacked
us you know been sitting in the
restaurant I would imagine heads were
turning uh yeah again this is California
I mean we were out at dinner with
Chamillionaire last night and girls were
screaming
I want to talk about your calendar usage
for a second last time we talked about
calendars you seem to be dialed in
you're using all kinds of calendaring
platforms yeah
um I want to talk about differentiators
for a second are there major
differentiations that you see beyond
kind of user interface branding
one over the other from a functional
standpoint
um
uh
yeah I I'm stuck on Google Calendar now
uh partly because every device
it syncs well I mean my iPhones thing so
that my iPad sings with it my Android
devices sync with it you know obviously
Google's going to sync with their own
calendar right you know and uh
Windows and Mac and everything syncs
with it so I I can use it no matter
where and I can use your computer and
use it right so it's great to have a
cloud-based calendar
um
and it's going to be hard to rip that
away because because even if you
designed a better counter with Plan cast
info information or TripIt integration
which actually there is some triplets
next week you can actually see what trip
it did
so let's try to put these things in
rental car and yeah I actually overlaid
my Foursquare data which is an
interesting visualization you start to
see where you checked in these will be
where you're supposed to be at what
times yeah but kind of coming back to
your point
Paradigm shifting calendar let's assume
that more or less they're all in the
same bucket I mean I understand all the
kind of you know sailing points you're
making as far as Google Calendar is
concerned even amongst the early
adopters which you're kind of sitting at
the top of that
what's your sense in the kind of
openness and the ability to adopt
something that radically changes the way
we look at our time and when we manage
our time it's gonna be tough it's going
to be tough to get me away from this
right now uh because of the lock-in of
iPhone and Android and iPad and windows
it has to work everywhere and it has to
be built in I mean if you could convince
Steve Jobs to put your new your new
calendaring as the key we're working
yeah you know and I don't think that's
gonna be an easy thing to do
you know I mean yeah it's just really
gonna be tough I I mean I that's why I
like tungle because it uses Google
Calendar it doesn't try to replace her
it doesn't try to go no you can't use
Google account or sorry it uses what
what works it's sort of Flipboard same
thing right Flipboard
looks really cool but underneath it's
all Twitter sure right right or Facebook
and it doesn't try to replace Twitter or
Facebook it just says those things are
what they are and they're not going away
and we're gonna use them and we're going
to use them and hide them a little bit
but we're going to use them to create
something beautiful that's the beauty of
it that matters not the
now you know what are the limitations I
mean you're a busy guy and that's you
know when you look at your calendar
you've got all these kind of dynamic
moving pieces around you yeah and then
you've got this kind of static calendar
sitting in front of you they're not a
disconnect between those two homes a
little bit but you know like yesterday I
spent an hour on the calendar and
looking and I and I looked at where I
had conflicts and stuff like that and I
had to renegotiate some things and it's
it's sort of a pain but it's not
it's not painful enough you know to get
me to
I I'm not sure that the pain is enough
and it's certainly not for most people
yeah I have a more complex calendar than
most people do you know most normal
people do I mean Executives would see my
counter go oh yeah I understand that
sure Bill Gates when I met him was
scheduled every half an hour you know
and so you have you know they would tell
me you have 15 minutes with Bill Gates
and he was going to ask you these three
things so be prepared sure and that was
it right you get out because every
minute of his time is like two grand
outside right you know or whatever it
was you know I think our meeting with
him was like we just spent a BMW you
know
it's like in a place of your mind so you
really think about how you use the
resources of somebody right like that
right where like my friends go yeah
let's go drinking you know
um if you were to project out four or
five years what would be the kind of the
number one thing that you would like to
see that would really kind of well I I'm
I'm really into series into the series
uh idea
and it's close
you know it's not just Siri because
there's a bunch of companies that are
working on voice I'm working on
artificial intelligence and working on
web service hookups and so we're really
close to getting that Allen K Dyna book
you know that we talked to and it does
stuff for us you know what's the surfing
like today in Half Moon Bay you know
what's the way
there's a boat buoy who's twittering
right now every hour the wave height so
there's an API wow right so but it's not
hooked yet right you know oh how many
people are checked in on Foursquare at
the TechCrunch conference that's going
on right now there's an answer for that
there's an API for that but it's not
hooked it what if it is what if you
could talk to something and find out and
answer to everything you want to do you
know oh we I need lunch where should we
go for lunch you know hey talk to these
things you know can you get us a
reservation for noon it's 12 for four
people and I'll go and find out you know
oh yeah they have an open table for you
want to make the reservation sure
and it'll go and put that in the Open
Table and lock it off on their device
you know sure and then tomorrow morning
I wanna a massage you know at the Ritz
you know is there a spot open sure you
know and I'll go and talk to the rest
come back and say yeah they're spot open
that data can also be proactive at the
same time right in the sense that you
can wake up in the morning advertising
the new kind of advertising right
because I didn't know I wanted a massage
but the Ritz could say hey you know what
we know you're down the street right we
have an open slot and we'll give you 50
off and we know you have an open slot
but even in terms of even better right
you know or they can make a a group deal
you know oh we know three of your
friends are gonna be at the Ritz tonight
because they make reservations you want
to join them right no that's a little
weird but you know you could play around
with that kind of thing
um or bring three friends three friends
in check in on Foursquare and get a free
dessert or something you know they could
do all sorts of yeah weird offers like
that but there's lifestyle data there
too right and so as an example
um you know good morning Robert it's uh
85 degrees outside and the waves are
high so be great over the next two hours
for you to go surfing if that's what you
want to be doing yeah right well and it
also
I mean the digital world knows they go
mountain biking now right that's a
change in my behavior but it has a map
of where I'd ride right because I
haven't ridden it yet today it's like
when are you gonna go right right sit in
your calendar for it I mean and all this
stuff is weird Serendipity it's like
um you know if somebody knows I'm
mountain biking then does that change
the rest of the day in some way you know